Speaker 1: Hello, everybody. Welcome to The
David Pakman Show. I'm producer Pat Forde,
filling in for David today as he continues his
paternity leave. Of course, yesterday we had Tdps
correspondent Luke Beesley fill in for David.
He did an excellent job. He really set the bar
high. So we'll see if I'll be able to meet that
threshold today for you and then the rest of the
week we're still trying to figure out, but I can
assure you that David will be back before you know
it. Let's start things off today by talking
about day four of the January 6th hearings,
which took place yesterday. And the theme of the
day was focusing on how Trump pressured state
level officials, mostly Republicans, mind you, to
overturn the election results. There was testimony
from three Republican election officials,
Georgia Secretary of State Brad Raffensperger,
who at this point we're all very familiar
with his deputy, Gabe Sterling, and Arizona
House of Representatives speaker Rusty Bowers.
They were all pressured to do Trump's bidding
and what I would argue was criminal influence by
the former president. But we'll see if the Biden
Justice Department and Merrick Garland agree.
Even though these three refused to go along
with Trump's wishes, the then president would not
take no for an answer, and he kept harassing them.
During the hearing, we learned that members of
Congress also tried pressuring these officials,
including Representative Andy Biggs from Arizona,
who called Rusty Bowers on the morning of January
6th, asking him to support the certification
of the electoral votes. All three of these
people testifying, Raffensperger, Sterling and
Bowers, received threats from Trump supporters
after they refused to go along with the plot to
decertify and send fake electors to various state
houses who would then send the electoral votes to
Congress. Perhaps the most emotional part of the
day was when Rusty Bowers explained the protests
going on at his home as all of this was going on.
And even up until now, apparently protesters
were bothering his gravely ill daughter,
threatening the family, levying baseless
accusations against him that he's a pedophile.
Let's play the moment from the hearings that was
perhaps the most emotional in all of yesterday.
Speaker 2: As others in the videos have mentioned,
we received some of my secretaries would say,
in excess of 20,000 emails and tens
of thousands of voicemails and texts
which saturated our offices. And we were unable
to work or at least communicate that at home.
Up till even recently. It is the new pattern
or a pattern in our lives to worry what
will happen on Saturdays because we have.
Various groups come by and. They have had.
Video panel trucks with videos of
me proclaiming me to be a pedophile
and a pervert and a corrupt politician and blaring
loudspeakers in my neighborhood. And leaving
literature both on my property, but arguing and
threatening with neighbors and with myself. And
I don't know if I should name groups, but
there was a one gentleman that had the three
bars on his chest and he had a pistol. And was
threatening my neighbor. Not with the pistol, but
just vocally. When I saw the
gun, I knew I had to get close.
And at the same time on some of these, we had a
daughter who was gravely ill. Who is upset. By
what was happening outside. And my
wife. That is a valiant person. Very.
Very strong, quiet, very strong woman.
So it was disturbing. It was disturbing.
Speaker 1: Bowers went on to read an entry
he wrote in his journal around this time,
wherein he said, quote, I do not want to be
a winner by cheating. I will not play with
the laws I swore allegiance to. And that
really used to be what America was all about, that
Republicans and Democrats could argue and try to
win as many votes as they could. But then once
you have the election and the votes are counted,
that's it. You tally it up. The loser concedes to
the winner. The winner takes office, and the loser
has every opportunity to run again the next time
if they want to. But you don't parade around the
country saying that it was all rigged and that you
really won and trying to overturn election results
by pressuring officials and all this stuff. We had
this long tradition of doing it right or mostly
right in this country up until Donald Trump in
the 2020 election. In addition to this moment,
Raffensperger spoke about when Trump pressured
him on that famous phone call to find the, quote,
11,780 votes. And Sterling spoke about how
he in real time debunked Rudy Giuliani's lies
about Georgia election officials supposedly
counting fake votes for Biden and Trump,
despite the fact that Sterling had debunked those
claims, decided to amplify the claims nonetheless.
So one would maybe look at this hearing and
think that, okay, maybe Trump supporters could be
convinced by this because the accounts in these
testimonies are coming from Republicans. So they'd
have no agenda here, right? They're not Democrats.
They're not just trying to say that Biden won for
political purposes or anything like that. However,
in the Trumpists eyes, these people are RINOs.
They're not true Republicans because they're
not true Trump supporters. So they don't count
right. They can be put aside and discounted.
So, you know, these people are largely too far
gone. Maybe we just shouldn't try to focus too
much on concerning ourselves, with trying to
convince them. And instead, maybe we should look
at these hearings as a possible way to get towards
pressuring the Biden Justice Department and
Attorney General Merrick Garland to press charges
against the former president. But given that
we have this long tradition of not prosecuting
former presidents, I'm personally not going to
hold my breath. But it's still good to learn
all the different things that we're learning
about because of these January 6th hearings,